When using automatic stitch patterning,
we don't want to distort the edges of our
knitting. By taking time to ensure
that the edge needles knit and not pattern
will make it easier to seam piece
and to work increases and decreases.
For example, when knitting tuck or slip,
we don't want those edge
stitches to tuck or slip.
When knitting with a lace carriage,
we certainly don't want the edge
stitch to be an eyelet.
Preventing the edge stitches
from patterning is important and it's done
differently depending on your machine.
On this Singer machine,
with this stitch pattern,
I can't easily predict when a tuck is
going to occur on the edge stitch.
Here I can see the tuck stitches on this
row and the edge stitch is
knitting correctly.
But on this row the pattern is
trying to tuck the end needle.
By tucking the edge stitch,
the knitting will be distorted.
To prevent this, put the end needle,
maybe two needles into"D" position or
pull them all the way out every row.
This will prevent those stitches
from tucking or patterning.
Now when I work a decrease,
I'll have two plain stitches and I'm not
messing around with tuck
strands on the edges.
If you look closely,
the tucked edge will be more difficult
to seam where the plain edge will
be neater and easier to seam.